[Musique]
arias que s'est intéressé aux sports que
personne ne regarde et après tu aller
dans la rue tu as fait quoi dans la rue
alors j'ai été posé des questions en
français sur leurs goûts fashion adjabia
ça c'est très drôle vous allez voir vous
allez voir très très bon le magnéto
aussi d'andrea salon dès mardi les
parties bon comme vous le savez je me
suis intéressé aux sports que personne
ne regarde et je sais qu'en voyant vous
poser la question de savoir comment je
peux pour être aussi musclé ouais non
bah du coup je vais vous donner mon
secret voilà j'ai beaucoup regardé le
catch sur l'équipe 21 et quand on
regarde le catch sur l'équipe 21 on se
rend très vite compte que les
commentateurs double la voix des
catcheurs malheureusement ils ont que
des physiques de commentateurs du coup
ils forcent un petit peu mais je vous
promets ça s'entend pas du tout chez moi
ok gorge médicaments pas avant six ans
[Applaudissements]
du coup je suis resté sur l'équipe 21 je
me suis intéressé à une compétition
d'haltérophilie a permis à des gens qui
suivent ce genre de compétition et
j'adore c'est vrai souvent c'est les
gens qui n'ont ni sfr sport ni been
sport ni canal+ ni une vie en général où
est le plus drôle dans ce genre de
compétition et je suis pas stéphane bern
- l'une vit alors voilà le plus drôle
dans ce genre de compétition c'est les
commentateurs qui ait said adressé des
compliments aux athlètes malheureusement
les compliments c'est pas leur fort du
tout patricia string
qui lorsqu'elle est sur le plateau face
à la bam et ressemble à une
franca qui auraient un petit peu grossi
c'est lui qui aurait un petit peu trop
forcé sur les looks ou non qu'elle se
regarde mes notes musquées os x quoi ça
sert à ça je peux mourir j'ai pas envie
de me bagarrer avec du bon ensuite j'ai
continué alors on va parler d'un sujet
sérieux c'est le classement de
l'olympique de marseille
pour l'occasion j'ai regardé le match
sur ille on a regardé le match sur la
chaîne tarp aime bien la chaîne locale
marseillaise alors sur cette chaîne ce
qui est bien c'est que les amis des
animateurs peuvent interagir avec eux
via le live
malheureusement via le live on se rend
très vite compte que ses amis se sont
pas du tout rencontré à la bibliothèque
c'est notre but audrey qui la connaît
sur des apéros francky francky je sais
pas si tu ne connais freinage que le
parfum qui les fera qu'une garde à vue
badea perd aussi dans cette émission
c'est un peu comme le métropolis un deux
salles deux ambiances mon côté ça parle
foot de l'autre ça parle pas foot à la
fin d'année c'est le seul qui faisait
les étrennes aux petits aux petits
employés l'avaient fait l'essai et la c
qui touche pour laure et là bas c'est
quand tu perds ton facteurs toi qui a
gratté quelques mètres allez savoir il
avait pas que les époux et voilà pied
les petites mains qui travaillent pour
toi corner
et en plus d'avoir de très bons
analystes footballistiques ils ont aussi
un critique cinéma est à l'écouté et
leonardo dicaprio policy un pizzaïolo
tunisien de treiber est acteur mais ça
paye et on reprend le ballon
gosling mais qu'est-ce qu'il est bidon
comme acteur il a deux expositions sur
jean claude van damme delà de l'heure
actuelle a laissé une pizza au fromage
c'est parler foot habitudes et prochain
j'adore bon et comme vous le savez hier
soir aussi c'était la rencontre entre
l'inter de milan et barcelone
bien sûr pas pourquoi je vous regarde
quand je parle de foot en plus ma maison
mais j'adore le foot ça façon
playstation certainement est donc juste
m'occuper de lui vous ne souhaitez pas
vous n'avez pas la lire cette chronique
est justement hier le défenseur du fc
barcelone qui est quand même gerard
piqué qui a quand même pécho shakira
ouais c'est vrai voilà bah je tire à vue
qu'à être depuis qu'elle est avec lui
elle fait des pubs pour décaler plus
avec lui je crois pas qu ils encore la
très bonne session en finir avec son
corps ensemble à la mairie l'un d'eux
pour l'apa voit la bomba est
malheureusement malgré les jets avec
elle hier malgré le fait qu'il est pêchu
shakira je vous rassure les mecs reste
très humain et peut toujours se [ __ ]
la honte en deux secondes 5 devant tout
le monde
[Musique]
baba
alors après j'ai enchaîné j'ai continué
à regarder sport sur les télés locales
mais là j'ai un peu mis sur pied masi
bonus suis tombé sur un télé-crochet
l'équivalent de n'oubliez pas les
paroles mais diffusée à la réunion dans
cette émission
les cadeaux sont pas ouf heureusement
les animateurs ont trouvé une petite
combine pour rendre des cadeaux un peu
plus sexy et on a vu les gens qui nous
regardent à la réunion bien sûr il
regroupe les abysses pas du tout
d'accord milan ferait la famille
gagnante trois nuits d avec petit
déjeuner avec petit déjeuner aller dans
la rue
elle démarre à dax est ce soit avec la
médecine et ça va changer les directs
après tp1 ça s'enchaîne dirais je suis
né dans la rue comme vous le savez les
français sur la chaîne du prêt j'ai
voulu un petit peu testé les goûts de
nos fashionistas pour l'occasion d'en
créer un look sur la base d'un sac de
couchage
on l'a mis sur un modèle et on a mis ce
modèle dans la rue on a demandé aux
patients de le juger
au début ils ont été un peu méchant mais
quand je leur ai dit que ça avait été
design et par une star internationale
ils se sont un tout petit peu avisé le
parti
alors comment tu t'appelles laurence
sais que tu suis un petit peu là mais ça
va vous êtes un pro des fashionistas
ouais ouais on va dire ça comme ça un
peu acheté ce complique et du coup
qu'est ce que tu penses de ce look c'est
une horreur
[Musique]
je confirme c'est une horreur j'apprécie
pas trop vous brouillez pour tout ça pas
du tout non non alors c'est ma
collection de rihanna merde prête à le
dire avant bah ouais fallait nous direz
vous alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ce look est pas mal et basket ça va bien
avec le style est tout ouïe
franchement ça va j'aime bien c'est
stylé qui pourrait le parquet je ne sais
pas si je les porte très bien ces sites
web pourrait tenter way avec des talons
par contre quand on peut rêver non plus
arrangé a présenté ce soir de rihanna
qui ont éclaté pourquoi pas qu'est ce
que tu penses débat de la collection
dialogue quoi ces anti ch'ti c'est un
jeu plus ça c'est un chapeau ait et
design et aussi par l je te laisse
l'essayer de tout je veux te regarder
ouais je pourrais dire que je t'aime
bien ça dérange pas d essayer d voilà
comme ça
ah non comme ça non c'est pas mal ouais
mais bien d'en poser la tortue trouve sa
collection real est original c'est joli
c'est comme els toi
[Applaudissements]